this is what Japan's Next Generation
stealth fighter will look like it's a
joint project with the UK and Italy
marking Japan's first major military
development with a partner other than
the us since World War II
analysts say security considerations in
the region are changing driven by two
main factors
prompting countries to rethink their
defense strategies
the first and Main challenge it seems to
me is North Korea is continually testing
ballistic missiles and violating U.N
sanctions because that's an unstable
situation at any time
second is really the great power rivalry
the intensification of I call it an
action reaction uh engagements between
China and the United States militarily
Asia Pacific is where the economic and
Military rivalry between the US and
China is being played out
the US has been challenging China's
expansive and increasingly assertive
claims in the South China Sea with what
it calls freedom of navigation
operations
China's military and political pressure
on Taiwan to accept Chinese sovereignty
has also increased tensions in the
region we're now back to the normal flow
of modern history where the world is
divided up into competing great powers
and completing power blocks and that's
what we're seeing in indo-pacific region
it's inev that competition is inevitable
conflict or war is not inevitable but
it's more of a possibility I think going
forward than it has been looking
backwards
the growing geopolitical uncertainty has
seen countries unveil new strategies for
the region that includes Australia's new
security and Technology pact with the US
and the UK
it's also set off an arms race as
countries seek to modernize their
Weaponry but not everyone believes
military might is a useful deterrent at
the defense show in Tokyo anti-war
protesters have a clear message all
one important thing for stopping the
wars and conflicts going on now is
getting rid of weapons
[Music]
that message unlikely to be heard in the
corridors of power
Florence Louis Al Jazeera